for the tampa bay rays this afternoon
it's going to be left-hander josh
fleming taking the mound and taking the
ball looking for the series sweep here
against the mets one on one out
the one hopper out to adamus to allow
one first base
two oh oh oh mike's limp uh oh hamstring
oh no
conforto coming up a little bit lame
coming across the bag
six four three double play and now we'll
check on conforto to see if he's all
right
oh boy
well yesterday jake hager made his major
league debut now he's taking over in
right field for michael conforto who
appeared to injure his hamstring coming
across the bag at first base it's he
looks fine until he gets right on the
bag watch the right leg
that's what it looks like he's grabbing
up high in that hamstring too
and he knew it immediately
now the mets have been plagued by
injuries lately strowman five and six
career and fourteen starts against the
tampa bay tampa ray's first bout of the
season for g-man choi
who was a real favorite in tampa bay
and he strokes the first pitch he sees
the other way and the left so welcome
back
regiman joy joked that one the other way
just another day in the lineup not his
first day out
whacked in the air to left field dom
smith back a couple of strides and makes
the catch to retire lau and the side
retired after one no score to the second
inning we go and there is no score both
sides with a hit
smith quick work for fleming to pick up
his first strikeout two up two down
now the one-two pitch got him swinging
and he got him chasing in the other
batter's box reaching across the plate
josh fleming has now retired five in a
row through one and a half we go to the
last of the second inning with the meds
and rays scoreless
and strowman with a little hop after
striking out wendell that's his first
strikeout
inside fastball
there's the sink at the last minute
started around three inches inside and
then got right in the corner perfect
pitch
it's grounded into the shift
lindor is there on the right side to
throw out mejia
and it's a one two three inning for
marcus strowman in the second no score
back to the mound for josh fleming
and that will take care of mccann three
strikeouts i love the way that fleming
is able to split the plate with those
right-handed hitters cutters in sinkers
and change-ups moving away and that
cutter tied up mccann and
got him the first out so they're just
dropping like flies now for the mess oh
man
mcneil who had played on friday sat
yesterday d.h today to try and
limit his
exposure with
what had been a cramping issue with his
hamstring in his back and now mcneil's
out of the game and mazika takes over as
the d.h
runner takes off a wave man to miss
gazette on strikes
we're going to head into the bottom of
the third each team a hit and that's all
so far
he's got another hit this one shot
toward right center one big hop hangar
over to cut it off joy
two for two
oh there's a shot back into deep left
center field that baby's out of here
manuel margot on a two-one fix turns it
around
and gives the raise
a two-numbing lead
fourth home run for margaux the fourth
home run allowed by strowman and here it
is well just a a nothing fastball no
sync no real run
and manuel margot that pitch flattened
out and he absolutely crushed it
francisco mejia back in the lineup
hit by that pitch the raid's going to
get a base runner to begin the bottom of
the fifth
ray's had the lead off man on first time
that has occurred today
the adamus
right center
well hit and that's what it's gone
willie adams takes it out to right
center of the first pitch
and the rays now lead four to nothing
number five on the year for adamus well
dwayne right there the two seamer you
get that launch angle swing and that
pitch stays right in the middle of the
plate
and adamus able to just catch it and
throw it over the wall
deep
out into right center field that's a big
one right there going from two to four
fleming will depart after five innings
and only 53 pitches and we're going to
see diego castillo
and he gets a wave and miss
right back with the slider
yeah diego castillo sharp with both of
those pitches we've seen the velocity up
there in that 97 range and then the
slider on top of it there's a great look
at the grip and then there is the action
that gets the strikeout and here's
patrick mozika left-handed batter
as mazeka drives one to deep right field
back toward the wall and it's out of
here
patrick mazzeka's first big league hit
is a home run the legend of patrick
mazeka continues to grow
his fourth career rbi his first major
league hit and it leaves the ballpark
and it gets the mets on the board it's
now four to one
inside fastball
oh and it bled out over the middle and
he was all over it
taking over as the d.h when jeff mcneal
had to leave the game
and he makes like a dh
he hit 16 home runs for binghamton in
his last minor league season we're back
to begin the bottom of the six marcus
strowman in this 4-1 game
brandon lau
after that first pitch and he nails it
back into right and good bye
the rays reestablish a four-run lead
hitting their third home run in the last
three innings of marcus stroman he had
given up three home runs
all year covering seven starts
and with the span of
actually just a little over two innings
plus has given up three home runs here
today well trying to throw a cutter
and run that ball in on brandon lau and
it doesn't get there what got there was
brandon's barrel
alan mchugh out here in the eighth
inning and
now cutting the mess
got him with the slider
well that's changing the eye level
yeah
yes it is and then you get that just
wrapping it around the corner
and he gets a reach right there
and then just ran right away breaking
away from mccann
and that's the second strikeout and out
number two in the eighth well here it is
look how far off the plate that goes i i
mean that's the thing the sweep on that
slider
and it just goes and goes and goes the
bat is not long enough how many times do
we say that
fly ball back into center field phillips
still going back he's there to make the
catch we go to the bottom of the eight
here's troy he's two for three in the
game today
got a base hit on the very first pitch
he saw back in the first inning and
strokes this one up the right field line
a hop and to the wall extra bases here
they're gonna wave meadows around on the
double by joy
a three-hit day
welcome back g-man choi
three for four today and a double to
drive in a run in the eighth
that makes it six to one and will margot
heads to the plate ground ball that
deflects off the ads into short right
and here comes joy he's going to score
hustling down to second throw there
gonna be in time to get margot
the race pick up another run
joy scored from
second base
and margot called out in second go to
the ninth inning raised with a
comfortable 7-1 lead and cody reed on to
close it out
one two a shot into right margaux is
right there and the rays win it
a one two three ninth inning for cody
reid
7-1 the final score